reporter wird ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution 28 grad
unterwegs hat die höhe damit der
eröffnung haben
den größten satz dass man selber pilot
ich das ganz klar die hand aber daraus
als 850 und wohl zum einen flugsimulator
was sehr authentisches gefühl geht zum
folgen
diese drei herren haben seit ihrer
kindheit denselben traum
traum vom fliegen
[Musik]
ihre freizeit investieren sie in
flugsimulatoren selber eingebaut in
echte cockpits wie hier bei dieser
boeing 737 an sich schön batterie stelle
wo vom herbst war die stelle
so haben zb die sorge dass man selber
nicht richtig fliegen kann
[Musik]
wir hatten hier nachdem die frau sich
aus dem koffer und ich weiß wie sich die
jungs ich bin nicht gewachsen berichtete
stimmt er wird was also tun wenn der
traum nie war wird und dieser film
handelt davon dass man auch mit einem
ersatz traum abheben kann wenn man nur
genügend daran glaubt es ist etwas ganz
großes dass markus lang im oktober 2015
nach england lockt mit seinen freunden
wähler das ausgediente cockpit eines
jumbos kaufen um darin einen simulator
einzubauen
natürlich reden müssen
weiter
habenicht
er kaum erfüllen
aber mit dem hydranten bereit sie
bewusst
das ist halt ein handschlag und
brandstiftung
auf einem ehemaligen militärflugplatz
steht die boeing 747
noch ist er die nicht definitiv
abgeschlossen
und zehn betreuer jetzt wird es spannend
ob dort sachlich jetzt der frühere
motorstart der ehemalige konsum von mir
die tatsachlich aufgezeichnet
überschwemmen potenzielle hat markus
lang erfährt vom flugzeug für schotter
dass diese noch einen anruf von einem
interessenten erwartet die schweizer
kriegen das jumbo kommt mit nur wenn
kein angebot eingeht
bis sich der mögliche käufer meldet
inspiziert markus lang den jungbusch und
mal aus der nähe
auch wenn er da und dort schon etwas
schimmel angesetzt hat
ja das ist jetzt sicher sein traum
kommandozentrale vor dem vor ein großer
vogel ist rima cockpit für die piloten
hätten flaschen jungs größte plus jetzt
nicht doch noch platzen heute mittag ist
der absatz funktioniert hat er nicht
aber es ist herrlich kühl absolut schon
als kind zu markus lang davon geträumt
jumbo pilot zu werden wenn man auch ein
auf der flug auf rote rosen geschmückt
und hercules das ist das wo mich
fasziniert ich sehr gern alleine pilot
werden hat ein aber relativ lahm ist
dass das
die schweiz nicht realisierbar ist
willig im 3d bereich im werk eine kranke
kommt das geht einfach die flüge haben
oder die schweiz geht an die
schmerzhafte lang darauf dass er
wenigstens das cockpit kriegt noch ist
die frist für ein kaufangebot nicht
abgelaufen der flugzeugflotte hängt
immer noch am telefon ob die pläne der
schweizer im letzten moment durchkreuzt
werden markus lang lässt sich nicht
entmutigen
er nimmt mit einem englischen techniker
maß das cockpit da für den
straßentransport nicht breiter sein als
vier meter 80 das ist vier meter
naja das ist es etwas kühler ist das
gold wert ist von großer routine so
diese windows windows vorvermieter
rankings und gastfreundlich wenn ja dann
endlich ist das schicksal des jumbo
cockpits besiegelt
[Gelächter]
so wie hans lufft aus kocht und isst
eine website look ganz gerne tue ich
dann beim raum prozent günstiger als im
hessischen triebwerk conti hat jetzt das
cockpit an das ist wirklich so ich sage
ein befreiender moment haben jetzt
wirklichkeit projekt vorstellte zurück
in der schweiz
hier im flieger museum dübendorf soll
der jumbo simulator zu stehen kommen am
liebsten prominent in der haupthalle
fraglich allerdings ob das überhaupt
machbar ist
als euro gezahlt aus das ist es so dass
davor sich weg schieben und werden dann
tor hinauf palette rowley und polit
positionieren das ist der plan
die vandalen thomas zu sein was ich das
ungefährlichste hände bevor hauptmieter
das ist das problem das schaffen relativ
gut
schließlich kommt alles anders
aber dazu später
das versteht doch keiner gehen wir nach
stehen verrückt klappt januar 2016
wieder ist markus lang in england
heute wird das cockpit vom rumpf des
fliegers getrennt markus lang bespricht
mit dem flugzeug verschulter die letzten
details dem jumbo geht es an die
innereien
vieles ist schon demontiert heute
verliert der flieger seine
schaltzentrale
[Musik]
muss ich sagen es ist brauch ja was da
gelaufen ist der letzten zwei monate wo
das flugzeug um renault die nec standen
die business class also die hand ich
zweimal ganz extrem
[Musik]
dann geht alles sehr schnell das vier
tonnen schwierig cockpit schwebt ein
letztes mal in der luft wie vor ist
definitiv gegründet wird
jetzt wird das flugzeug das flugzeug
sieht jetzt dass es wirklich so
förderstunden stunde an der tauber und
jetzt viel schneller
oben im jumbo klafft nun ein großes loch
und unten auf dem lastwagen gibt es ein
kleines problem
jetzt bereite ich 20 nicht unerwartet
aber jetzt werden wir danach wieder weil
die maximum breit die auf der straße
oder genehmigung ist viel kommunizieren
aber maximal ob das mittel um auf der
sicheren seite ziehen
[Musik]
so würde ich es aber was ich es klar wer
das sind fast ausgebucht
ja so muss ich meine weiß es noch nicht
sicher sein
nun wirds hocheffizient die polizei ist
nach alles in ordnung
weiter
[Musik]
das schafft
und während das cockpit unterwegs ist
geht es dem rest des jumbos an den
kragen
aus dem aluminium sollen später
getränkedosen gemacht werden
[Musik]
februar 2016 auf dem flughafen dübendorf
räumen helfer die halle aus und platz zu
machen für das jumbo cockpit
wer geht
[Musik]
eigentlich wollten die simulatoren bauer
das jumbo cockpit in der haupthalle des
museums platzieren
nur scheint es da keinen platz zu haben
sie müssen ausweichen
nur zweimal
das tolle ist der master knapp ist dass
wir ganz ganz heikel wurde und vor dass
er so eine riesen beat für egg gebiet
das wäre finanzielles des ausstiegs sie
aber auch ganz generelle riesentöter
auch beim alternativstandort spitz
probleme die zügel aktion gerät ins
stocken
und ich sehe mir die vollmundige
versprach aber eine gute idee im rahmen
der länder mit dem anschlag und
abstellen und stellt maschinen ganz ganz
schwierig werden motoren aktuell
astrologin csu hinterachse so schieben
die männer das cockpit auf sogenannten
schwerlast rollen durch die halle
dieses prozedere hat allerdings auch
seine tücken
als wähler wollen ist ohne skipper blöde
wir sind über den info ist jetzt muss
man mit der luft weil aus der rolle
wieder einmal wenig mühe sagt reagiert
und dem rad unterwegs
zum glück ist das cockpit solide
asianews kunst
es hat keinen schaden genommen damit
begleitet
sommer 2016 nach viel hin und her mit
dem jumbo cockpit verbringt markus lang
mit seinen kindern ferien auf einer
bündner alpen sätzen mit 21
der hans das areal folgen ausland wer
glaubt dass sich lang hier oben der
flora und fauna widmet der versuch das
natürlich tief zu halten will
gemeinsam sind für männer fehlen
flugplatz gesicht lieber spazieren sie
zu nehmen sondern muss das thema es
verlagert sich jetzt viel sie verdient
aber kam eine gute balance gefunden
das erscheinen seiner dass der 17
beide projekte sozialressort machen
leider nicht wiederholt werden da das
unbedingt machen kann daraus machen
regen dann macht er alles andere
entscheide ich nur gehabt also für mich
das ok wanne so fit sie braucht will ja
wenn es gern macht dann macht es gern
uns ja das freut mich dass es als hobby
gefunden hat
auch wenn markus lang darauf achtet dass
die aviatik nicht überhand nimmt
manchmal kann er nicht anders
dann trifft er sich mit einem kollegen
in kloten um richtig abzuheben
[Musik]
auch wenn er wegen einem sehfehler nie
pilot werden kann
zwischendurch darf lang sogar selber und
steuert dann ist er dem siebten himmel
ziemlich nahe
[Musik]
so wird der traum vom selber fliegen für
markus land manchmal wirklichkeit
[Musik]
eigentlich
herbst 2016 langsam nimmt der simulator
form an
peter kruse besitzer eines elektronik
unternehmens baut mit hilfe von
ehemaligen swissair piloten und
mechaniker das cockpit um alles in der
freizeit zum schaffen
die arbeiten sind aufwendig und dauernd
über ein jahr hier gespielt aber dann im
betrieb mehr auf oder elektrisch rettung
vieles im betrieb auf alles das gibt es
das gefühl wenn man vom richtigen flügel
und das ist ja ein strom haben das
plastik kießling aufgestellt sondern
hans gesamte abgeschnitten und wird
dadurch dann aber geschichte bei einer
niederlage vor dem gran zu früh
möglichst viel zum laufen bringen
gesteuert oder diese alte jumbo rein
mechanisch über stahlseile wollte trotz
vorwärts nun baut dieser pensionierte
mechaniker elektronik ein
damit kann dann auch das
simulationsprogramm über diese seien
züge bedient werden
[Musik]
verlobt habe dank des da nachher und
dass die kubacher 40 meter hindernis
bewegt haben und flogen nicht mit
drehungen fischverkäufer umgelegt und
bot sich schon so imposant bus an die
arbeit am unterboden ist anstrengend der
85 jährige lässt sich dadurch aber nicht
aus dem konzept bringen würde doch einen
kleinkrieg mit beamern wird die
computersimulation auf eine leinwand vor
dem cockpit projiziert es braucht noch
feinabstimmung bis alles passt und der
erste pilot virtuell abheben kann
im mai 2017 ist es endlich soweit
mitglieder und sponsoren der simulatoren
gruppe versammeln sich im flieger museum
zum jumbo einweihungs flug machen mit
rechts mit dem simulator mit dem eine
nacht später ist natürlich absolut
speziell nicht nur viel
freiwilligenarbeit auch viel privates
geld ist in den simulator geflossen
einige haben mehrere zehntausend franken
eingeschossen
wann gehst hand und ein ganzer tag
vorgängig mit suppe geriet und alle
unglücklich high und und schwärmen davor
und sichert anderen dann ist das halt
sehr sehr schön jetzt dreieinhalb jahre
nach projektstart ist alles ready for
take off
vieles lässt sich originalgetreu
bedienen der technik verantwortliche ist
zufrieden
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt da vor
dass sie sterben zu lassen
bosch sowie acht flüge fest so gut wie
auswahl wächst um bei den dort auf ihn
zu
der autopilot passt also lieber in der
schwemme roxy war der schriftzug brachte
natürlich mega happy das ist doch jetzt
eine mehrjährige expedition gehe und
dass das alles zusammen kostet sechs
euro
vom plan über finalisieren ist viel zeit
und schweiß und stunden kommen plant
eine völlig
[Musik]
auf ihre eigene art haben sich diese
hellen den traum vom fliegen erfüllt so
gut simuliert das ist schon fast echt
ist
[Musik]
reporter wurde ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution